what do you guys think about this mike
Ward comedian situation in Canada that's
another thing Canada has wrong I don't
know the situation so so Michael Ward is
a comedian and in his special he makes
fun of I guess a kid who was at this
point only 13 years old there's a kid
who sings who travels to the Vatican and
he sings for the Pope except this kid
has Treacher Collins syndrome Treacher
Collins syndrome he he looks like kind
of like a bird he has like bird-like
features right yeah right so then so now
this guy Mike Ward who made fun of this
kid on the special and saying like oh I
thought he was dying so I initially
liked him but now that I know he's not
dying that he just is ugly you know
that's basically how he phrased this
joke yeah so he is now on trial or for
violating this kid's human rights
apparently now this kid's 19 and this
mike Ward is on trial for that what do
you guys think about that let me ask you
a question [ __ ] let me ask you a
question
does he look like a bird that's yes then
that's it but he was called let me ask
you a question is he ugly in just like
you know a society standard of
good-looking
I mean is he ugly I think he looks
really cute I'm just trying to save her
give me a photo give me a photo I think
he looks good I'll give you the job I'll
be the judge
okay give me the guy I'll be the judge
George let's have you pulled this
picture up to on the video on YouTube
what's his name Mike Wayne is Gabriel we
t-bird oh my god try retract that
Gabriel what Mike war there's a comedian
with musculoskeletal oh I'm being there
maladies not even that I mean he
obviously has a physical lab you know
see I mean first of all Mike Ward looks
interesting - but I mean sweetie this is
when he was made fun of it that was your
kid you know that you would be so upset
if someone called him first of all us
bad does not look like a bird at all
he's gonna say a different animal
it doesn't he looks normal to me oh I've
seen that looks like Bill Gates as a kid
you know what it kind of doesn't like
he's a smart nerd yeah he's a nerd nerd
look ya know the number one okay even if
he did look like a bird
right which he doesn't which I'm like
now angry about yeah I mean my
alcoholism is kicking in hey my relapse
over it
no my point is is that even if he did
have what's that Sam the kid that had
the UM progeria Nigeria right it looks
like a what an alien okay so I died but
people with progeria they look really
old maybe they look like aliens right
and if I said then I got sued over you
can't in America because freedom of
speech and also it'll be true I think I
think people are way too [ __ ]
sensitive yeah that's what this one
comedian who came in defense of mike
Ward said he's like look like you this
the whoever is parenting him is
delusional to think that the kid is not
gonna get teased at some point in their
life and especially if you step into the
public eye I mean he sang for the Pope
you have to be a little bit more
reasonable a little bit more realistic
like manage your expectations of the
world manage your expectations of how
people are going to react you know your
kid has abnormalities you're putting
you're obviously giving parental consent
for him to be you know it's okay okay
let me just say this okay
what's that documentary about that girl
that looks like a stick oh yeah a stick
figure because she doesn't figure stick
figure no she looks like a branch brace
it's a human alright I know I just
saying we love her I love her here well
wise yeah I love it too I cried mm-hm
and my point is is this and she got
famous because that famous because but
somebody put on YouTube but world's
ugliest girls that broke my heart right
so me and now she did a TED talk and now
she has a documentary about her
a lot of money she's a YouTube channel
and life worked out yeah it works out ok
because she got strong that's one of a
point though is so this this kid right
here right that looks like a bird right
doesn't look like a bird
hey whatever you know min it's like
listen I got made fun of I don't have
any defects
I mean people used to call me [ __ ]
all kinds what are some of the things I
don't remember jump like it's a dumpling
or whatever you're right because this
kid could actually be like you know what
I have a medical diagnosis called
Treacher Collins syndrome you you'd be
like oh it's just born like this I was
just born like just normal you know yeah
but my point is is that we all have
physical flaws and whatever and whatnot
yeah except for 23rd except for Tony
Thornbury ok but what if you were this
kid's parent how would you react to that
comedian and I would I would be like I
would be like you know he's telling you
know I'm sorry sweetie
what do you call you I'm him I'm hammer
yeah oh yeah what you yeah why Hitler
sign put don't meet the face okay fine
don't make the face alright don't you do
the phone sorry that's why okay so yeah
hey Dad
yeah comedian Mike he really hurt my
feelings call me a bird yeah yeah wait
you sing Gaelic you agree no no you
don't look like a one but when I want to
say it to you son Simon his is that
Simon um let me just say something yeah
is is that people say mean things right
and number one it doesn't necessarily
mean it's true and number two it's like
you know that's just life people get
made fun of right and what we're gonna
do is we're gonna make you spiritually
and emotionally stronger cuz you're
special and I love you so much and mom
loves you so much and we're gonna get
through this and you don't look like a
bird okay
keep them a check your your song we do
that yeah yeah yeah I
that was actually very good speech yeah
you know I'm gonna say you're gonna be
the spokesperson for Twitter my mom yeah
yeah yeah yeah nobody no backup
you use your ugliness towards something
you here's the thing about I don't know
anything about raising kids but the one
thing I know for a fact is you got to
look them in the eyes and go no matter
what happens in life I got your back
yeah and I love you so [ __ ] much yeah
and you don't ever have to worry because
I'm mom and dad have you we love
unconditionally that's / that's a
perfect way to say it like don't do that
to just tell your kids like you have
your people yeah like this is all you
need anyways the world's a cruel place
but you have your people and we won't
let you down
[Music]